se le conoce como la transatlántica de
la libertad cuando se lanzó en 1978 la
ruta de ron estaba abierta a todos los
barcos monocascos multi cascos e imoka
fue creada para promover el ron y los
territorios franceses de ultramar sale
del puerto de sambalú y llega a la isla
de Guadalupe en el Caribe en un
recorrido que dura entre 6 a 9 días una
carrera muy francesa que a lo largo de
los años ha cautivado a navegadores
solitarios del mundo entero y a sus
barcos cada vez más sofisticados sus
ganadores se han vuelto legendarios
Michael Burch philippen el dos veces
premiado luego un boño y una mujer flojo
vencedora en 1990 No creo que este sea
un medio de machistas creo que hay
quienes tienen esa imagen pero creo que
es un gremio de marineros donde la gente
se estima por las cualidades no es para
nada Un mundo machista cualidades que se
necesitan para enfrentar Esta carrera en
la que el mar ha cobrado vidas y barcos
en la primera edición manureva
desapareció en las costas de las azores
junto a su tripulante Alan colas ocho
años más tarde el catamarán aguayal
naufragó en medio de una tormenta en la
que desapareció para siempre sus keepers
án último uno de los más rápidos y que
parece Volar Sobre el agua el ultin de
la bong pupilet mide 32 metros de largo
23 de ancho y 37 de alto
son los barcos más rápidos normalmente
uno de los nuestros llegará primero a
Guadalupe y pues son barcos difíciles de
maniobrar en solitario porque son muy
grandes y muy potentes Pero son muy
placenteros por la velocidad y podemos
hacer la travesía en prácticamente una
semana
La pasión por la aventura predomina
sobre el riesgo este año un récord de
138 barcos competirán de los cuales 5
serán capitaneados por mujeres se
esperan más de 2 millones de
espectadores sumando la salida y la
llegada el día de partida será este 6 de
noviembre